I think the best business for someone to
start if they've never started a
business before is something that they
already have tangential experience with
one of the big fallacies of your first
business is that it's going to be your
last business and it almost never is and
so the idea is like it's much more
valuable to get started on something
that you have a higher likely of success
on so that you can get some faster
rewards for the behavior of getting into
business and then from there get some
resources get some skills and then you
can have a better perspective from which
to make a jump or a decision on what to
do next